le moelleux
je viens d'arriver
aujourd'hui
c'est par là on va
[Musique]
santo
ce concert
m
c'est
[Musique]
compte
ouais
[Musique]
vas-y
m
[Musique]
paul wahl
moi
[Musique]
le
je
[Musique]
super
c'est quand je cours je veux gagner
[Musique]
la motion
ats
[Musique]
lamoureux
je aulas
il
le hainaut
[Musique]
la ville
toner
jeu dangereux
elle
[Musique]
là je sais que deux tours
pas sûr
je vois
[Musique]
un jouet l'eau
laissé libre
que j'ai
vous avez vu la
savoie
oui ça c'est l'association
donnant déjà cage
[Musique]
et
va pas s'éterniser pas mois
le mois du lat
c'est comme ça
[Musique]
préférant
parlement
bourreau
[Musique]
fabien de symbole
on
est là pour les annuaires
c'est comme les plus impliqués ne peut
rien dire mesdames et messieurs je vous
remercie d'avoir
répondu
les autres et
roseraie toi d'ailleurs
ça se voit et de nous voir si nombreux
que nos coffres aussi l'importation
ainsi qu'aujourd'hui à paris en volume
et la qualité des lumières et des
libertés celles ci n'ont plus qu'à ce
douloureux matic et
intentionnelle de julien assange
françois ruffin et cerise année avec ses
marins de trois ans pris l'initiative
avec l'argentier résidents
cette somme est le fait du peuple akouè
la fois ci comme ça note
t
il avec un petit pécule monde nous
embrouiller ne sommes présents depuis
longtemps si 19 mai 2006 puis liste
et les faits alors j'ai l'honneur
de vous présenter
la
brise est la compagne de julien
hommes
je suis bretonne et le papa
mais les avocats de
donc inutile de rappeler que nous avons
déjà mené
sans un homme de combat où la coupe des
heures
les autres et d'être ensemble et séparés
cela puisque quatre ans s'étaient
déclarés
prêts à nous mais
nous avons formidablement la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et
citoyenne
et les reproduit on ne veut pas des
meilleures la patrie devons
d'honorer ses engagements et apporter un
soutien longtemps attendu à des
funérailles
et résistant
demain matin
le phénomène mondial
il a déclenché
avec la publication
d'un certain nombre de documents
a résolument
changé
je
voilà le jour et remercié m
l'association des collectifs
de femmes
l'arrangeur et exceptionnel
puisque c'est nous mêmes comme stable à
convaincre
nos amis
du royaume uni
julian assage
salia aux états unis
oui déjà connu les pires tortures
psychologiques
et voudra simplement à
venir
je veux dire de la
france face aux verts
afin de nous apporter toutes les
informations
sur l'asile pour julian assange
à ses
adversaires
jeanne établi que
[Musique]
deux repas par jour
le ferons-nous des signataires de la
résolution le député ruffécois il ya
peut-être là que les au vif donc j'en
remercie john shipton d'art de julian
assange est c'est la nourrice la
campagne pour leur venue en france je
remercie aussi tous les militants en
france en angleterre en allemagne
partout dans le monde qui lutte avec
constance avec rang durant sans que
soient libérés ce combattant de la
vérité je vais d'abord exprimé là au nom
de tous les signataires de la pétition
avec de la résolution par une habitude
avec cédric unanimes elles ont rédigé
une proposition de résolution pour que
la france accorde le droit d'asile à
julien d'instance nous avons rapidement
obtenu des signatures de tous les noms
des groupes de gauche et communistes
socialistes un souvenir des groupes de
droite les républicains de lui lui mais
aussi d'agir de liberté territoire
d'anciens marcheurs indépendants
mais aussi des bancs de la majorité il
ya beaucoup beaucoup signataires du
modem à ma surprise presque et il ya
aussi des internautes et les rôles m
pourquoi pourquoi il ya un tel
dépassement des frontières partisanes à
mon avis sur le cas de julien à georges
parce que les motifs pour le défendre
sur divers sur plurielles j'en vois au
moins deux fois il ya d'abord les droits
de l'homme les droits de l'homme du
droit d'un homme qui n'a jamais été jugé
n'a jamais été condamné et qui est
pourtant enfermés depuis près de 10 ans
maintenant pour aucun crime le
rapporteur des nations unies sur la
torture ni smales a décrit jeu le site
julian assange doit à présent être
libérée immédiatement
réhabiliter et à indemniser pour les
élus et l'arbitraire auquel cette
explosion ensuite deuxième motif il ya
les doigts la presse et comme reportage
je suis attaché
quel est le seul crime que julian à
sargé me c'est d'avoir divulgué des
vérités notamment sur lesquels
américaine en irak en afghanistan c'est
comme journaliste qu'il a suscité la
colère de washington
c'est comme lanceur dallaire tous les
risques tous les jours une tradition
avec à la clé 100 soit 175 années de
prison enfin je romps après le jet
motifs et qu'il tient à coeur il est
patriotique qui a révélé julien dray
sans que l'état français jusqu'à son
chef était espionné par ses amis
américains comme le souligne eric
dupond-moretti lui-même avec voir ce
justesse avant de devenir ministre de la
justice je le cite je suis kg les dupond
moretti on va tout de même rappeler ce
qu'il a permis de révéler il a permis de
révéler en france le jacques chirac
nicolas sarkozy et françois hollande
avait fait espionner par les américains
ça n'est pas rien n'a permis de révéler
également que pierre moscovici et
françois baroin deux ministres français
l'économie avait fait l'objet d'une
opération d'espionnage écologie conduite
par les états unis ne serait ce que par
orgueil pour services rendus à la nation
nous devons accueillir du la naissance
le pays dans la crau disait il faut
protéger toute la liberté la liberté de
la presse mais la liberté des individus
aussi julien assange incarne à la fois
la liberté de la presse et la liberté
des individus déjà ajouté pour
l'accueillir nous manque marquerions
aussi la liberté notre pays voilà
pourquoi pour ces trois raisons qui se
cumulent qui se mêlent des signataires
de cette résolution qui suggère la peine
tous les cons parlementaire de
l'assemblée voilà pourquoi nous
réclamons que la france accorde le droit
d'asile à julien dassin
[Musique]
si vous voulez je peux dire à vous pour
éclairer fenêtre tout le monde sur
l'état de la procédure je vais la
regarder
donc pour rappel julian assange est
détenu à la maison d'arrêt de belmarsh
depuis deux ans dans des conditions qui
sont extrêmement difficiles avec très
peu de visites la vie de cette famille
mais qui est ce contexte la visite de
ses deux avocats mais qui ont cadré il
n'a pas de matériel pour travailler pour
préparer sa défense et s'est en prison
depuis deux ans l'a rendu extrêmement
fragile sur le plan de la santé je
rappelle les propos qu'il avait elle
rappelé qu'ils sont ceux du rapporteur
spécial des nations unies qui qualifie
état de julian assange comme celui d'une
victime de tortures institutionnels
psychologique en des motifs qui avait
conduit le premier juge anglais il ya
quelques mois a refusé la demande
d'extradition qui est formulée par les
états unis il ya quelques semaines s'est
tenue l'audience devant la cour d'appel
à londres dont l'objet était de statuer
sur l'appel interjeté par les états unis
d'ici la fin de l'année on aura donc
deux possibilités soit la cour de
justice anglaise voudra rejeté l'appel
des américains à ce moment là
vous formulez mesdames messieurs les
parlementaires devient absolument
fondamental puisque julian assange sera
un étranger sur le sol anglais et sans
une fois fortes comme la france pour
l'accueillir les états unis pourront
dans le cadre d'un mouvement migratoire
par exemple vers son pays d'origine
l'australie le rec appréhender donc tout
ce processus pour lequel de nouveaux
bétons un servi à rien soit
effectivement l'appellent les états unis
prospère et on retournera dans une phase
de lutte intense je rappelle que le
motif qui a conduit la juge anglaise à
ne pas donner droit aux états unis est
un motif très lieu le droit de l'homme à
savoir que l'état de santé de julian
assange ou aujourd'hui ne permet pas
physiquement cette extradition il ya un
risque de suicide est un risque pour sa
santé qui est trop grand au regard de la
justice anglaise pour le moment
cependant partout dans le monde et
monsieur shipton qui est son père pour
en témoigner parce qu'il a accompli un
tour du monde dans énormément de
l'endroit de monde julian assange a un
support démocratique populaire
extrêmement fort mais il n a trouvé un
écho institutionnel c'est pour ça que je
pense que la famille et nous remercions
énormément l'assemblée nationale députés
qui ont oeuvré on va dire collectivement
et dans quelque chose qui est trans
politique qui est bien de tous les bords
et qui est vraiment très important pour
qu'on puisse avoir ce débat et cet
éclairage médiatique si important pour
eux aujourd'hui j'ajouterai que j'ai vu
de julian assange il ya environ trois
semaines à la prison de belmarsh et qu'
il a rappelé trois messages que il
souhaitait que vous puissiez entendre le
premier c'est son attachement personnel
à la france il ya beaucoup d'autres pays
dans le monde mais julian assange vivait
en france avant de se rendre on va dire
presque fortuitement en angleterre là où
il a été finalement appréhendé par les
états unis si ce n'est juridiquement au
moins qu'actuellement il vivait en
france si la famille française la
plateforme wikileaks qui est celle qui a
révélé ton de choses bénéficiaires à la
france était une belle forme et hébergé
en france et donc ils espèrent beaucoup
du peuple français dans toutes ses
dimensions vous avez quitté la salle en
tant que pays des libertés les droits de
l'homme et il semble que ces derniers
temps la france sur ce terrain là pas
fait entendre sa voix à sa juste valeur
et que une des raisons pour lesquelles
nous sommes si heureux que vous acceptez
dans ce seul mouvement politique encore
une fois trans partisan de d'apporter
leur soutien à ce citoyen c'est parce
que lui même est très attaché à ce que
la france incarne deuxième chose il a
rappelé que cette affaire n'est pas et
puis la sphère politique
l'appareil judiciaire est
instrumentalisée dans le cadre de ce que
monsieur mélenchon a souvent eu des
procès politiques
qui sont en réalité des faux nez pour
cacher un combat politique que julian
assange à venait en des années contre
les états unis dans un cadre idéologique
et journalistique et que les états unis
ont délibérément décidé
d'instrumentaliser en créant une
procédure qui est totalement
artificielle mais qui a pour effet de le
maintenir depuis deux ans dans une
prison de haute sécurité comme s'il
était un terroriste et qui présentait un
risque sur la sécurité des autres or
monsieur assange peu importe les débats
et politique les polémiques est un
journaliste un éditeur de presse et n'a
jamais le fait de mal à qui que ce soit
d'ailleurs les états unis on peut même
retirer 15 jours avant la première
d'audience l'argument selon lequel il y
aurait donc eu leur mi engranger des
gens qui n'ont jamais donc elle était
identifiée qui n'ont jamais existé et
dernier point et c'est en en étoile mais
ce que vous venez de dire que julien
assange a insisté sur quelque chose qui
qu'il a mis en avant en se demandant
pourquoi le peuple français ne les fait
pas davantage dans son combat puisque il
a raté que wikileaks avait toujours été
favorables un enjeu de souveraineté en
révélant que la france avait certes des
alliés des des rapports politiques avec
ses alliés mais qu'il fallait pas
oublier que wikileaks avait permis
d'assumer les enjeux de souveraineté
fort les ménages l'oppression république
et d'autres choses dans l'activité
récente ont émergé je rappelle enfin que
à côté du cadre d'extradition des
révélations journalistiques extrêmement
sérieuses ont mis en avant que quelques
semaines avant son interpellation il
avait fait 25 de celles qui se réfugient
pardon à l'ambassade il avait fait
l'objet puisque les journalistes ont
caractérisé une tentative d'assassiner
par les services secrets américains
c'est suffisamment sérieux pour que ça
soit abordée de manière sérieuse pour
montrer qu'on est face à un homme qui
parce que il a mis en plus un crime
commis par des institutions se retrouve
aujourd'hui traitée comme un terroriste
sans procès équitable souli un
traitement inhumain et dégradant avec la
certitude que si la justice ne rejette
pas le laver les états unis il ne peut
pas y avoir des états unis un procès
équitable le concernant puisque tout a
été fait pour que ça ne soit pas le cas
donc j'ai envie de vous dire qu'il vous
le dire on aime mais parce que j'ai eu
la chance de le voir récemment merci au
nom de julian assange d'avoir gagné et
d'avoir réussi à mettre partis
politiques qui normalement sopo
dialoguent ensemble dans un même projet
commun au service d'un citoyen qui n'est
certes pas français mais qui a de la
france dans son coeur et qui attendent
beaucoup de la france donc le merci à
tous elle est évidemment
je vous rappelle que plus que jamais
aujourd'hui c'est important puisque dans
quelques semaines le sort de monsieur à
100 sur le terrain judiciaire va changer
quoi qu'il arrive
enfin vous avez fait a voulu insister
sur
cette démarche d'unité le feu de paille
je voudrais maintenant et à jéricho la
visite ils représentent la vanille
monsieur
donner la parole à michel
cabannes et
voilà comme si adp
si vous n'avez qu'un actions non la
balle tout le monde s'y met revenons à
lui dans le sol alors je suis
effectivement signataires de cette
proposition de résolution
je n'ai mas ont été condamnés juste
assez la pression scrabble il a fait son
travail de journaliste il a fait plutôt
bien il a fait tout de même très bien
cette lui un allié de la france et lui
il l'a démontré
contrairement aux états unis qui le
condamne ces types ne l'ont pas démontré
dernièrement
il a démonté il a dénoncé samedi
d'espionnage envers nos chefs d'état
envers nos ministres de l'économie
l'espionnage ouvert loomis de claudie ça
aide un peu quand même pour qu'on va
contrecarrer quelques contrats notamment
avec l'australie et d'origines de
générations
alors je parlais de pronoms pour finir
je pense que certains décident de
vouloir enfermer nous déciderions plutôt
de la dgos
[Musique]
jeunes j'ai
alors senti
l'appel intitulé à très bas coût 6 1
mais c'est un bordel essentiel ce
problème
allez voir les prisons en france qu'à
l'étranger et il ya deux avocates me
ludot passionner pour ce vieux difficile
indignant voudrait parfois sans se
battre c'est l'idée dû demander l'asile
en france et c'est sur ce point que
intervient précisément là je vais me
confiant un peu dans la presse et c'est
normal je me suis rendu compte à son
dossier à temps tous les français le
connaissent pas
pour l'inviter à me connaître d'ailleurs
je n'ai pas d'actions chez cet éditeur
et je vis le petit cv qui vient de
sortir quatre postes à celle qui vient
les projections ont lieu à michel c'est
le formidable documentaire qui était
projeté samedi il faudrait la voir pour
parler sérieusement du dossier j'ai eu
chaud n'est pas sur les modèles changent
et petite enfance ces formules qui est
musique bon côté a beau répéter
compliqué que j'ai très vite et
longtemps nous sommes arrivés nous il ya
deux ans à l'idée qu'une seule chose à
faire dans ce mondial est elle proposée
est lui encore flou et donc il ya deux
moyens le premier en tout cas tout comme
l'instance qui consisterait
pas de secret mais ce n'est pas le chien
fr consistait à faire demander une sage
l'asie elle fera comme n'importe quel
même bien le problème c'est qu'on
demandait lundi alors ce sera qui est
indéfendable il faudrait l'accord des
référés thaïlandais quand la frappe pour
les interrogations normalement demander
l'asile ne fera que si on est sur le
territoire français pour la seule asie
de droit commun il ya mis sur pied
ils régalien que le président afrique
peut offrir demain matin ça je crois
qu'il faut s'accrocher à la constitution
elle est précédée en france nous avait
deux ans demande la commencèrent servent
à travers nous c'est le collectif avec
lecteur de d'âge qui est de l'entrée
comme un spécialiste dax 30 est là jean
paul et sa femme de guillon on a essayé
de fédérer depuis un an les différentes
forces pour arriver à ce résultat
aujourd'hui avec les cultes et hédoniste
à nous pour célébrer avec l'ani on
s'entend très bien qu'aujourd'hui
commence un jour nouveau puisque en
fonction de l'écho de ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui à avoir du jus qui viennent
on peut espérer bousculer l'exécutif
c'est ça qu'il s'agit qui a dit que je
dirais que c'est triste la saint glin
nourrir mon dieu c'est riesch et
l'américaine comparé au titre qu'il faut
absolument faire un électrochoc
président il ya encore des mois des
années donc l'asile ragagnin c'est
quelque chose d'assez simple à ne pas
confondre effet le président parce que
je rencontre souvent des sympathisants à
ne pas confondre avec une demande
d'asile qui avait été fait pour ça que
la ferme filocher presse vient le monde
hier cinq ans qui n'est pas une demande
faite officiellement donc elle n'a pas
été officiellement rejetée par le
violent qu'il en débatte il y avait un
communiqué elle était en disant que ce
débat une demande urgente et que de
manière déplacée dans les formes donc
les tables dans les formes il n'avait
pas la rejeter dans le cra existe à
votre produit mais au fond de moi il y
avait une ceinture
c'est en fait mais j'ai offert donc nous
sommes là tous d'accord malgré les
divergences d'un ami de 3 nous sommes à
tous aujourd'hui au lancer un message
fort ce soir au bénin la république
qu'il accorde l'asile politique le plus
rapidement possible à julien ça on est
pas les y aurait un bras de fer qui
n'aspire américain mc saïda partager la
charge deux fois dans la place forte
avec les britanniques musulmans que
l'angleterre refusent de partir à celle
ci a transhumé car on va partir de la
prédiction mais une pensons qu'il faut
faire serait peut-être de goldbach lui
aujourd'hui ça se ferait
qu on peut espérer que l'appel qu'il va
partir dit s'ils
réussissent à faire décidé ma course et
parce qu'ils pensent de dire si personne
ne m'aurait et bien sûr le mur d'arrivée
ça c'est qu'on a fait ce petit axe aussi
pour les députés qui sont là vous avez
autres débouchés ou laper l'eau que
malgré que va signer janvier c'est parce
qu'il renvoie cette proposition de
résolution ça va rester jusqu'à
aujourd'hui nous allons devoir prendre
le téléphone mais il faut que quand la
motion présentée à l'assemblée cette
révolution qui est parfaitement
démographique pas seulement 24 il faut
une majorité pour la beauté donc on
arrête pas ce soir je modèle message pas
pour eux plus aiguë et ce à deux autres
voiliers du rallye fait quelque chose
pareil le téléphone en orient je crois
que c'est madame je veux envoyer un
message trésor je crois aux forces de
l'esprit comme l'autre fois qu'ils ont
envoyé des saracens soir dans sa cellule
je pense que il peut se passer des
choses qui chante 7e et d'énergie
terrain disciples ont eu libre en faveur
de sa liberté
merci
pour le travail exceptionnel qui a
réalisé la même crise a rien peut pas
tous les citer vous êtes
un
travail exceptionnel
pays des magasins regrets par rapport à
d'autres et vous l'avez cheminée
j'espère que vous allez vous faire
cheminer un peu plus cette semaine nous
avons des textes qui passe à l'assemblée
nationale justin lyonnais
doit
la transmettre
au shopi à nous mêmes et la cnam si vous
voulez bien je pensais que vous pouvez
donner la parole à joe simpson et le
pavage ici
merci infiniment monsieur
le
je
voyais une déclaration un tout petit et
classe donc les luminaires donc je les
honneurs de traduire les cheats nb je ne
suis pas qu'elle est loin de là le
traducteur si c'est avant tout un des
militants nos policiers qui ont placé
pour longtemps
une réputation plus aux flegmatiques et
je suis généralement pas impressionné
par la présence de l'auteur dans une
salle je dois avouer que peut-être à
cause de la cause à cause de cette cause
qui me tient à coeur
je risque d'avoir quelques hésitations
au niveau des traductions et ça fait
quatre jours que je suis maintenant je
suis intellectuellement épuisé je ne
sais pas comment lui fait mal donc les
six mois je suis fatigué je l'imaginé
donc
pardonnez moi si j'ai quelques
défaillances
gecko émotionnel
c'est un grand jour pour nous tous quoi
de comploter plusieurs sans qu'ils aient
ici il est insurgé j'aimerais le lancer
pourquoi qu'il se perde quelques uns
dans une poche et l'a pas été et si on
veut accorder la nationalité
c'est qu'il est
sur les jambes
pliées merci et surtout les
[Musique]
occasions
il a dit vouloir travailler je vois que
nous allons l'écrire moi je fais à votre
pouvoir venir en france l'eau bouillante
juste une semaine
jaurès fut
julien d'une heure face à une adversaire
du même
influence la vie sauvage le masque est
mauvaise car l'ancien ghetto scandale et
que vous ne résout pas les problèmes
il a dû pour détrôner 12 ans your thing
vous avez tous deux
français
malveillance à se développer dans une
audience après l'audience me possède à
85,15 audience que je
souffrais d'un tube dont la folle
histoire dans le documentaire exercice
de fin joven un écran défendre julien
bontemps qui colle le prêche fruit de
l'union des gauches de la répression
contre la presse entre nous et massa et
frais louage mal mais d'après ce que je
veux dire est ce que parce qu'il a
mariné la vase du
brent russell
je parle de la possibilité pour une
éducation industrie et du quai vauban
est grande ouverte et est en conséquence
le gamin de vergio conduit les yeux des
grands gars les pays en question bien
plus fort les termites
et du régime des éléments de l'éducation
et non les anges les connaissances des
population est la population de
fond il règne
de fort mural est prise le 6 de gamme
c'est un produit hors de ces zones
grecque pendant une politique de grande
qualité du response ténès une bva et me
voir l'enseignement bien qu'à mon tour
s'est offert
la tête de
six engagés dans cette aventure de
bilodeau six soldats moment de signer
chez moi comme les indiens selon le même
commentaire
'le
france je ne sais
je pense que seule la france consomme et
julien
france wine spirit france de savoir
qu'une histoire de la france une fois
que son esprit
process systems une french spirit
bien dans l'esprit français c'est une
tuerie
à nice le tiers de la résistance et de
l'hyper des données en
vous et vous remercier tous ceux que
[Applaudissements]
vous avez là
rien et on m'a sauvé c'est sûr nous
sommes les seuls qui peut me voir
m waouh je suis donc en mesure de lui
transmettre leurs
soutiens
l'initiative
joggers life is very
idjeur la vie de julien devant
un cinéma munich
[Musique]
car il est plus faire leurs preuves
lorsqu'on ferme en espoirs espagne
notons qu est ce qu a laissé des traces
sur son corps
j'aurais aimé ce massacre et le risque
d'une pollution
extérieure hacking qui disent que vous
êtes en train de tuer
les aspects 7 il faut le sauver
c'est une récompense cette impossibilité
la même celle qu'avait sorte son arrivée
j'aurai les sprints frêche qui est en
train d'être efficace
ps le ps indre à f2 de plus grâce à ce
qu'il avait prouvé
pourquoi ce moment et à bien jouer à
chooz corner le seul e
vous faites de saper progressivement
l'ordre international sa page ne sait
vraiment mais seul le fait de salon
xbox 3 qui l'a révélé la torture and
housing
torturé
alors un client je ne sais pas si vous
savez les tests 1,25 à
l'importance
de ce
projet est envisagé d'assassiner un
salaire de ces à l'intérieur
ils sont transformés en ce moment
maintenant
et les enclos
je vois
ces racistes et menaçants
que nous construisons
un risque récessif
environnement c'est pas rien
[Musique]
ceux ci l'ont
sauvé julien dépend de notre capacité à
cause de ses
réponses julien représente symbolise ce
principe
notre hymne national
[Musique]
on adapte à droite
mais aussi
pour ma part je sais que notre
démocratie
merci chers fidèles à maurice pour votre
courage
c'est là
la force de votre farce fort ce que la
vie qui vous anime merci à vous john
shipton
shabbat y
viennent et le ceux qui le disent à
l'aise
devant seront évoqués des aspects
tout c'est quand même me julien sage
avec un notamment
c'est que certains hameaux de chefs
d'état et des textures un peu décevants
mais
ce serait aussi il ya mieux il ya
indiqué mme anna le détail leurs mères
qui sont pas inquiets les états unis
d'amérique
avec
l'irak ensuite le désordre mondial qui
s'est instaurée et enovia moyen-orient
et à l'afrique
c'est à dire que selon mme harel
historique est ce que nous allons faire
aujourd'hui est ce que fera la face d'un
régime rpt on le sera aussi voilà ce que
parce que jouer le père d un homme ne
paraît pas très important d'autant que
nous allons pouvoir de discussion à
sommet cette semaine sur
pourquoi telle science 0,9 à berck
voulait se tiendront une chose la
discussion ni de
bercy la parole pierre dionne le
chauffeur le dit - il y en france il ya
toujours eu à 28 euros du bien passage
une compréhension transpartisane
combat qu'il mène parce que cette
étiquette confondues trémoureux avec des
partisans de la liberté et la liberté de
la presse jeter moins deux mais pour ma
part de l'extraordinaire courage julian
assange car il ne faudrait pas croire
que sont à leur physique et morale et
commencer à l'école
sa rétention actuelle actuelle est
rencontraient en 2012 dans un stade de
l'équateur il vivait dans une pièce de
10 mètres carrés et c'était son seul
horizon devant la fenêtre il y avait une
bibliothèque pour empêcher en écoute
synthétisée dans la pièce depuis
l'extérieur car les anglais et nord
américain mais installé une écoute pour
savoir ce qui se disait à l'intérieur et
assange à manifester dans cette
circonstance une
capacité de sang froid et de maîtrise
qui était absolument du commun
il était fait rêver à ce moment là et
nous allons considérer le me torture des
conditions dans lesquelles il a été
retenu pendant ces années puis le
président lenin moreno de l'équateur
avait acheté de revenir sur la parole
donnée par l'état votre bien est ce qui
a permis l interpellation de julian
assange qui est de cette manière est
passé d'un traquenard judiciaire à un
autre de celui qui lui avait dérobé
tendue en suède puis ensuite en double
en angleterre par cette opération vous
devez savoir que ce sont des traquenards
une série d'api car le fait que monsieur
assange et été capturé et mis en prison
a permis à d'autres en équateur de
poursuivre les deux ministres des
affaires étrangères qui avait donné
l'asile à monsieur assange des deux sont
poursuivis par l'état équatorien et on
leur demande des dédommagements sont de
l'ordre de plusieurs centaines de
millions soit avoir accueilli à ce que
voulez vous ça pour qu'on se dise que
c'est un traquenard politique ça n'a
rien judiciaire c'est une volonté
acharnée de venir à bout de tous ceux
qui d'une manière ou d'une autre cour et
les élus en assange parce que les états
unis avaient mûri veulent se venger
voilà j'ai une petite histoire on a tout
essayé
cela sollicitations des uns et des
autres il faut s'élever le boulot
magnifique qu'il fait par les
associations qui maintiennent la flamme
du combat on a essayé la demande d'asile
on a essayé
la demande de légion d'honneur on a
essayé et ça veut dire de celle ci je
suis ému et je le maintiendrai que je
leur disais s'il en faisait la demande
nous pourrions demander à notre
présidence de la subite de le
naturaliser et à partir de là nous
serons partie prenante de la dispute
puisque ce sera à nos citoyens qui
seraient dans la sphère c'était
j'emprunte rapports avec les états unis
voilà je vous aime je voulais vous dire
mon admiration élections simon paraîtra
peut-être des ailes
mais regardons john
aimé trouver le même sourire
resplendissant et demi de viable et
c'est quelque chose extrêmement
impressionnant en se disant que c'est
peut être là qu'il puise la force de
résister à ceux qui le financent
elles aussi
des mères jure c'est sa capacité à faire
évoluer l'impossible je
conçois que ceux qui veulent poser des
questions pour papa
à la campagne
à l'ami proche et fidèle à notre année
monsieur coderre qui a permis
d'organiser ceci au river est membre de
l'association de voie d'échangé dans
l'esprit se voit il en arrive tous ici
c'est notre réussite et le côté de la
ville il faut traduire quand même récit
d'un fermier vous passez au niveau où il
réunit ses affaires mais il veut
paraître
au drame
j'ai une question d'ordre technique est
ce qu'on pourrait se rapprocher pour
faire la prise de son nom présente ci
serait plus à voir
chers jeunes chères
puisque nous intéresse pas les bras
devant la perspective
s'il ya quelques questions de la presse
écrite de la sorte que le monde
s'enrichit de réponse qui pourrait être
faire de cirque elle est ensuite dans un
petit moment la baisse des linéaires et
par les varois ça bougeait et stylia
s'unir à l'espoir monsieur dallas vous
dit que vous intéresser à d'autres
agences transition juste une question de
vision qu'ont affronté ces procédés pour
que cesse
cette notion celle conditions
d'évolution arrive dans l'hémicycle un
débat et est ce que vous avez à un
bien-être pour que cet essai est réduit
vous avez décrit comme un peu déclenché
dès lors que ce soit la mêlée les
semaines passent les deux victoires
et seulement d'une initiative
parlementaire il faut trouver une place
dans une niche
donc qu'une premier les signataires en
marche on peut espérer que salines de là
mais voilà d'espoir quand même un peu
raisonnable et donc voilà il va falloir
prouver qu'il ya les signatures de tous
les partis une niche qui accepte
d'accueillir une proposition de
résolution faux julian assange
est la position des listes alors ce
concert de l'altérité la vicodin
que donne une réponse précise parce que
effectivement on est dans le calcul et
cela passe avec des jeux soit à
messieurs ont lancé le mouvement il faut
que beaucoup de députés qui y tiennent
en un peu toc du fait un point que je
rigolais dimanche donc la première niche
kg dispose c'est celle du groupe dont
fait partie jean est
non superman avait plus trace le
quatrième niche dans votre route donc ça
doit être une année mais il espère que
dans le groupe de la france un sou mais
il y aurait une niche d'avant donc ça il
faut pour certains je vais débuter mais
la première date sur veulent en venir
dimanche c'est quatrième une niche qui
permettrai le vote l'interdiction ne
laisse du temps pour que l'on ramasse et
on recompte a même si l'homme de députés
et le reste pour voter à la majorité des
présents cette proposition de résolution
qu'il entendra une force candidats
vous avez déjà
rêvé être au cas où j'avais déjà
à winnezeele alors ses positions ce qui
est nouveau aussi c'est la deuxième
circonscription du nord françois
sionisme est un oui il ya plusieurs
quatre cas de figure possibles il
s'applique ni à l'ordre du jour de la
majorité si on autorise t la correction
cherche un vote majoritaire se serait
donc logique que 60 comme n'a semblé en
général et pas sur le temps d'un coup de
crosse position sur quel qu'il soit
parce que nous on a quand même une
journée par an pour faire des
propositions seraient déçus les son
ultime diverses et variées en soirée et
en plus ça veut dire que si c'est dans
une profonde si c'est dans une niche
d'un groupe d'opposition il ya quand
même une probabilité ce soir votre
négatif partie est mal but recherché et
c'est vrai que les résolutions peuvent
être aussi à l'initiative du
gouvernement se trouve est rare mais
c'est aussi possible que si les outils
qu'ils avaient des tickets manière mais
c'est aussi ce qu'il est et qui est sur
la table je le redis sachant que l'essai
entraîne des changements aux rêves pour
laquelle nous pourrions discuter du cas
de julian assange des aînés lancera
herbe ou plus généralement c'est le
texte sur les lanceurs qui examinait des
deux mains à 15 heures nous avons un
contre vous déposer un amendement pour
être un nouveau critère dans le droit
d'asile explicitement lié aux lanceurs
d'alerté pour que l'idée la démarche et
notre seigneur au moins décrocher dans
l'imaginaire une fan page sur le sol
français pourra faire ce type de
demandes puisque c'était particulier
pour les lanceurs et les actes à
l'étranger et qu'il ya des tas de
domaines je vois autant le domaine
numérique et qu'il n'y a pas des
révélations qui sont faites qui peuvent
intéresser la france qui pourtant sont
faites à l'étranger et pour lequel de
légende des besoins de protection pour
pouvoir faire ces alertes pour l'intérêt
général vous êtes vous dit et donc à
plusieurs fenêtres de tir alors vers qui
la mode mais la rochelle ça reste la
même demain 15h
la vue j'ai vu
elle rompt bretagne dans la question et
la réponse la question vous aviez
conception des fusées la salle sur
julian assange le gouvernement avait
rappelé son attachement au droit et à la
coopération internationale avec la
grande bretagne laissant celle d'avant
bretagne régler ce problème ce que
souhaite julian assange les larmes le
père de julian qu'en venant ici c'est
rappeler à chacun que en réalité un des
enjeux qui était d'ailleurs au coeur de
wikileaks de l'émission de julien sens
et l'information aujourd'hui le peuple
français doit savoir qui et où les
agences voile incorporé comme quelqu'un
qui lui a rendu service et qui est
essentielle à l'exercice des droits
civils et politiques dans toutes les
démocraties mondiales à partir de là ben
nous on a le souvenir avec ses larmes de
se réveiller quand donald trump est
parti de la maison blanche la nuit pour
savoir s'il avait conclu gracié et cdma
et du coup une 9 une chose qui portent
éthique savons à quel point on est dans
un processus éminemment politique où
comme l'a rappelé stella il suffit
qu'une personne quelque part de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique qui appuie sur un
bouton pour que tout s'arrête donc après
ramifications politiques les dialogues
et les oppositions les combats ça c'est
le rôle de nos politiques et deux
instructions mes chiens qui vont pas
rendre le processus plus complexes que
ce qu'il est il suffit que le président
ils décident de reconnaître qu'il s'agit
exclusivement d'un combat politique et
idéologique qui doit stopper pour que
tout s'arrête la france et pas quand
même dépourvu de voile remis et la
possibilité parce que c'est ça que nous
sommes en train de parler au delà des
écrivains des ddt choses techniques de
savoir comment il pourra pratiquer une
déclaration publique officielle de la
france rappelant son attachement à deux
choses d'une part le fait que monsieur
assange images avaient été condamnés
pour rien aujourd'hui il est détenu
provisoire sans avoir jamais eu le
moindre procès et on peut déjà dire que
la souffrance qu'il a été imposé par le
processus judiciaire est inacceptable en
terre de droit fondamental qu'est ce qui
justifie cette souffrance cet
enfermement cette privation des droits
rien donc avant même de rentrer dans le
dossier toutes les démocraties du monde
devraient s'opposer à ce que quelqu'un
qui n'est pas à juger aujourd'hui est
connu un sort aussi difficile
inacceptable sur le terrain ses droits
fondamentaux et deuxièmement si on veut
complet dans le le nez politique alors
il faudra rentrer dans le dossier et
seront retenus comme l'a dit jean lui
plaisant succès c'est un dossier en
grappe qui en réalité ne mène nulle part
parlez moi de ne pas vouloir entrer
justement dans cette grave pour vous
expliquer comment les arguments des
états unis dans l'audience d'extradition
ne cesse changer tous les matins comment
est ce qu'en réalité on n'est pas du
tout dans un dossier judiciaire strict
avec les charges une accusation simple
je rappelle quand même pour que vous
compreniez qu'il est poursuivi sur le
fond tendent une loi de 1917 qui est
censé réprimer l'espionnage en temps de
guerre on est véritablement d'entente on
va dire quelque chose qui est
déconcertant sur le terrain judiciaire
et juridique et qui nous appelle à
revenir aux fondamentaux
et dire que quand le peuple français
fera de ce dossier quelque chose
d'important et quand les candidats à la
future élection présidentielle
prendront l'engagement que s'ils sont
élus il soutient que les gens comme je
les récentes parce qu'ils sont
fondamentaux dans la capacité des
citoyens à exercer leurs droits civils
et politiques on fera vraiment une
question politique c'est pour que ça me
brûle delà de ça nous avons essayé
demandé à ce que tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle en 2000 comme
200 villages aussi à soutenir cette
proposition parce que la voix de la
france c'est aussi la voix de l'exécutif
mais je pense que c'est très important
pour chacun d'avoir déjà pu créer son
premier mouvement politique important je
pense qu'aujourd'hui et par cette motion
qui j'espère va avoir le soutien pouvoir
rappeler que c'est un processus
politique qui se résoudra par la
question politique
il suggère au coeur ça n'a pas amusé
davantage aux autres et se compare à des
campagnes julien
de laisser s'approcher s'est viandé
micro vois ce que je vous suggère qu'à
voir le nombre ou les deux le lien verte
c'était une journée très importante pour
la mobilisation
[Musique]